life is stover many different
contradictions and one of the ones I
want to talk to you about today is the
fact that you have this big group of
people that always say think positive in
pods are always think positive positive
positive matter of fact there's a book
out there called the power of positive
thinking it was one of the first 10
books i've read norman vincent peale
phenomenal book I loved it but as life
kept going and as I was getting mature I
wanted to come out with certain values
and principles that cleared up my
philosophy to the point where I'm so
confident in the decisions I'm making
and when I get to that point I'm so
confident because I'm resolved I trust
the decision I'm making because they
have a way I'm processing it in my mind
that I'm not overthinking it let me
explain you got power of positive
thinking on this side then you have
power of negative thinking on this side
by Bobby Knight and then I read how to
stop worrying and start living by Bill
Carnegie then I read Marcus Aurelius who
was one of the best emperors Rome ever
had he wrote a book called meditations
and he studied stoicism through Seneca
so I'm sitting you're thinking about all
this um who's right should I think
positive should I think you know
negative maybe this is good
should I just stop worrying and start
living should I be a stoic what should I
do and so here's the perfect system that
came to me and and and I want to help
you by the way anybody I coach and
mentor directly anybody I'd cos come to
ask me advice for all the time I tell
them I'm going to make a case to you you
don't have to believe it you don't have
to buy it but these are your choices
which one do you want make one of the
choices for yourself and go about your
business and your lot so let me get
right into it so first things first if I
just sit there and somebody says just
pray about it just meditate on it yes
I'm a praying man I started praying as
an atheist at 19 years old when I was in
the US Army 1997 September I was at that
time I was 18 years old a month later I
was going to be 19 I started praying and
believe me it's worked for me but not
alone by itself I will sit around and
say something's going to happen
someone's going to come and change my
life for me that's not how it works so
what do I mean by this let's just say if
I am in a situation health-wise that I
don't like my life let's just say I have
a business right now that I don't like
what I'm doing I have to ask the
question and anticipate what could
possibly happen if I continue going the
way I'm going right now
so step number one is anticipation what
is anticipation if I do this I'm going
to go out of business in about nine
months from now that's the reality step
number two is acceptance I accept this
if I go out of business okay cool you
accepted it then you don't have to
change anything anticipation if I
continue like this with my relationship
this is what's going to happen a year
and a half from that do you accept it
that's number two I don't accept it then
we need to come out and change your
approach to see what could happen
positively so anticipation number two
accept us I don't accept in its
preparation so then I have to prepare
and put a plan together on what I need
to do so in case that day comes I'm
ready for it
so I'm looking a little bit positive
that I'm going to do my part but
negative what if this doesn't work out
because this way is not going to work
out so anticipation step number two
acceptance yes great keep doing it no no
preparation next then implementation an
implementation is what once you prepare
you put your strategy together your plan
together I'm going to change my schedule
I'll change my dad I'm going to change
my relational model changes over time
and it's great then apply implement if
you take that approach you have to keep
in mind positive thinking and negative
thinking because crisis is going to
happen and you do have to think about
that everything's going to work out
because you feel like you're the
luckiest man alive I was on a podcast
this last week somebody asked me hey pal
what all this stuff that you've gone
through man how do you come to America
and and not stay bitter I said bitter
are you kidding me I said man the worst
day in America still better than the
best I lived in Iran the memories I had
when I lived here I have all my senses I
have people that like working with us
here we got a company that's growing
I've got I was able to experience what
it is to be a father to three different
kids of son two sons and a daughter I
got a wife I got living parents at the
age of 38 I'm the luckiest man alive
that's attitude positive thinking but
hey if I don't get my act together my
kids my family my business my employees
my staff my salespeople the industry's
counting on me to make the right
decisions have to anticipate excess
prepare implement and then I put myself
in the best situation to get the highest
return possible so the next time
somebody tells you just think positive
say hey man I think you need to watch
this video here because he's got a
complete
twist - what do you mean by thinking
positive hope that helps with the
contradiction of always think positive